zwar im niedersächsischen delmenhorst
ein mutmaßlicher brandstifter legt
montagabend gestern abend innerhalb
weniger minuten drei brände in
verschiedenen mehrfamilienhäusern die
feuerwehr muss mehrere personen mit
einer drehleiter retten darunter auch
kinder
drei brände innerhalb von 30 minuten bei
einem brand in einem mehrfamilienhaus
geraten menschen in lebensgefahr der
fluchtweg ist durch dicken rauch
abgeschnitten die feuerwehr aus
delmenhorst ist gerade auf dem weg zum
einsatz als schon der nächste notruf
eingeht wir haben jetzt innerhalb
kürzester zeit mehrere einsatzstellen
das erste waren gemeldet der
wohnungsbrand da sind die kräfte der
berufsfeuerwehr und der ortsfeuerwehr
stadt hinaus drückten zweiten
einsatzstelle stellte sich heraus dass
ein abgestellter rollator und unrat im
eingangsbereich also im treppenraum
brannte und konnte auch schnell gelegt
werden wir stehen eingetroffenen
einsatzkräfte der massivste ist jetzt
hier in der düsternortstraße hier kam es
zu massiven kellerbrand in einem
mehrfamilienhaus mit circa zwölf
parteien
zwölf parteien haus es kam zu einer
massiven verrauchung des treppen raus
dadurch war auch der fluchtweg für die
leute abgeschnitten herr mussten
entsprechend überhob rettungsfahrzeuge
und tragbare leitern durch die feuerwehr
gerettet werden es wurden insgesamt über
acht personen gerettet und acht wurden
auch den rettungsdienst vorgestellt
wobei sich jetzt herauskristallisiert
hat das 2 ins krankenhaus wo die anderen
werden noch gesichtet alle mit verdacht
auf rauchgasintoxikation
die feuerwehr musste auch kinder vor den
flammen retten die genaue brandursache
ist noch nicht bekannt brandstiftung
kann nicht ausgeschlossen werden die
polizei hat die ermittlungen aufgenommen